hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about the nutrients that make your
muscles grow
okay we're also going to be talking
about other things that will slow down
the breakdown of muscle so let's say
you're going into menopause you're
getting older and your muscles are
getting weaker and you're having a lot
loss of collagen and if your arm list
the videos for you or you just want to
build up muscle the myth is that you
need just more protein to build muscle
okay so check this out you eat protein
which is basically animal muscle you
might have eggs you might have fish it's the
muscle of that animal and you digest it
and your liver in your stomach and your
intestines and enzymes start breaking
down into these small particles or
building blocks called amino acids okay
amino acids are the foundational
building blocks of protein so it takes
certain acids it takes certain enzymes
to break it down alright and they're in
their stomach it's in the pancreas and
liver it's in the small intestine so you
have these enzymes so this whole
conversion of breaking down the protein
and then building it back up require
these nutrients okay vitamins and
minerals and other things so in other
words the purpose of vitamins and
minerals are are basically coenzymes or
cofactors to help convert the raw
material amino acids into body tissue or
other like fatty acids into a healthy
tissue so we need the vitamins for that
and we also need these vitamins and
minerals to support the enzymes which
are the magical workers that pull this
off and it's quite magical so we don't
need more protein necessarily we need
more of the nutrients the two top
nutrients that are mostly missing would
be potassium and trace minerals
potassium because we need so much we
need 4700 milligrams a day and there's
not a lot of people that are consuming
seven to ten cups of vegetables per day
so they're not going to get the
potassium and trace minerals because
it's missing in our soils so if you
don't know the trace minerals it's hard
to activate the enzymes alright there's
other vitamins that you need to like the
fat soluble vitamins vitamin
A D E and K but specifically about him in
a and but most people get those and you
need certain B vitamins which most
people can get easily and vitamin C
these are all necessary in the
conversion into actual muscle tissue
okay and of course if you exercise
you're gonna break down tissue and you
start building back up and that's a
necessary thing but I want to go through
some common issues that people have that
are might not necessarily relate to
nutrition in general it relates to
amount of sugar and refined carbs so in
the other videos I talked about insulin
resistance okay and that's a condition
where your cells no longer allow insulin
into the cell as much as it should so
it's kind of blocked and that's simply
because there's too much sugar in the
diet so the body shuts it down because
of toxic so it doesn't allow the cell to
actually allow the sugar to go in the
cell anymore but because insulin is also
involved in the absorption of protein
and amino acids you have this dual
effective now you can't get fuel but you
also can't get amino acids in this cell
so that's why diabetics for example have
a lot of weakness in the muscle loss of
collagen loss of muscle strength and
here's the animation how it works you
have the normal protein going in the
cell beat with the help of insulin like
a key and then over here you have
insulin resistance where the cell is
blocked insulin can't enter anymore and
thus you have less protein in the cell
less you have less muscle protein
collagen joint tissue you name it okay
so insulin resistance is one thing and
then you also have stress in general
those people that are adrenal body type
they're stressed out what happens
they're activating a hormone called
cortisol cortisol is very it's called
catabolic it's very destructive on the
muscles okay catabolic means breaking
down anabolic means building back up so
when you have the muscle breaking down
as particles in this animation you can
see these muscle particles are breaking
down because of the high levels of
cortisol it basically then converts to
sugar okay so protein is being converted
to sugar if you want another name of
that it's called gluconeogenesis
ss-sure glyco meaning sugar neo meaning
New Genesis meaning the generation of
the formation of formation a new sugar
from muscle eventually they get diabetes
because the blood sugars go up because
the muscle protein is turning into sugar
primarily taken from your quadriceps and
your thigh and the gluttonous Maximus
that's your butt muscle so you see these
cases with the adrenal over time they
have no but and they have no legs that's
all got in the middle part right it got
like a little try like a trunk and these
stick legs
that's the adrenal and that's what's
happening with muscle so you can have
excessive stress causing a loss of
protein you can have lack of nutrients
you can have high levels of insulin
because the insulin is not working
insulin resistance pre-diabetes causing a
lack of absorbable protein ok so here
are the do's you want to do intermittent
fasting in a minute fasting triggers
growth hormone growth hormone increases
muscle preservation and retention of
muscle and muscle building ok so you
need 3 meals maybe 2 meals a day ok I
have tons of videos on that you could
watch that this whole four or five or
six small meals a day not good it spikes
insulin it keeps your protein from going
in now let's talk about snacks adding
snacks spikes insulin again causes more
protein problems you would think that
having protein snacks between meals
going to help your muscles know so you
don't want to do any snacks because you
want to be intermittent fasting because
that way you can heal insulin resistance
okay now that's why the pre and post
meals or even protein meals is a bad
idea
Gatorade filled with sugar not good
because this sugar is what we're trying
to counteract because it's creating an
insulin resistance messing with your
muscles okay now is far as a lot of
people this is a mistake they make they
have protein powder so a whey protein
powder thinking they're going to drive
all this protein in the muscle but
that's going to spike insulin
you'd be better off having a fattier
protein then the more fat the less
insulin spike the better okay moderate
amount of protein okay three to six
ounces
don't go with like massive amounts of
protein like I see people just eating so
much protein thinking that's helping
them when it's just overloading the
liver your body can't handle that much
protein it just put stress in the liver
if you're 18 years old you can pretty
much handle it but eventually it starts
slowing down I don't even think at 18
you could probably handle too much then
we have the type of exercise if you ever
see a long-distance runner they don't
look very muscular do that they have
they kind of have smaller muscles
probably because of the carbo-loading or
just the glucose they consume if you
take marathon runners they have this
thing called GU which is just pure sugar
and they're taking this sugar they're
running out there doing a lot of carbs
unfortunately that's going to create
more insulin resistance and block the
muscle not to mention the sustain
exercise increases cortisol and it
causes muscle wasting a much better
exercise would be high-intensity
interval training because that can spike
growth hormone and preserve your muscles
as well short bursts of high-intensity
exercise full body very important sleep
is also necessary to increase growth
hormone stress is not good so these are
the things you don't want to do these
are the things you want to do okay so
hope this summary helped and go ahead
and apply it and give me your comments
hey I just wanted to take a moment to
thank you personally there's so many of
you that have gotten this book and the
feedback that you're giving me is
mind-blowing thank you so much I really
appreciate it if you wouldn't mind I
have one quick favor to put your
unbiased review on Amazon I would really
appreciate it thank you so much